okay so all of us are dead changes a lot
of things about your typical zombie show
whereas in most properties based on the
undead being bit is a death sentence
here the virus can mutate so that the
person infected retains their
consciousness nowhere is this more
apparent than inguinal the evil school
bully that ends up stalking the students
in the show as he attempts to exact
revenge on chung-san it really is an eye
for an eye and in the penultimate
episode guinam manages to catch up to
him during the entry the military start
to herd together the undead so that they
can bomb the area and both chung san
anguinam and get caught in the blast but
did they survive it well throughout the
video that's what we're gonna be
breaking down so come with us as we
re-examine the evidence to discuss
whether they're alive or dead if you
enjoy then please drop a thumbs up and
also comment below with whether you
think the character made it out or not
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into all of us are
dead okay so the first character that i
want to examine is guinam who goes down
the elevator shaft with chung san after
the missile hits the school the
explosion knocks them both back and
chung sand wraps his arms around him as
the pair tumble down the chamber
if we slow down the footage we can see
the fire engulfing them both but paying
close attention to green am you can make
out his body turning orange as the fire
engulfs him this starts to slowly break
him apart and the guy completely melts
in the blast disappearing before they
even get to the bottom after looking at
this closely there's absolutely no way
that he survives this because the guy is
completely eviscerated so rejoice fans
yeah we'll never have to look at that
stupid mullet again now because he takes
the full force of the blast it actually
provides protection for cheng san who's
head we can see at this point the
episode ends with us closing in on joe's
name badge and at this moment we also
move past the hand amongst the ash that
still seems intact kurt episode 12 and
we get a continuation of this shot and
can see beside the name tag what looks
to be lee chung-san if we look around at
the other corpses they're mostly in
construction gear and his body is the
only one that's clearly in the school
uniform therefore i do believe that this
is him and that he is in fact dead
however there are a couple of things
that could indicate he ended up reviving
after this and for all we know the half
bees might even be able to survive fire
damage now the majority of the cheung
sang being alive theory has to fully
hinge on him becoming a variant this is
something that is very very rare and as
his final scene happens shortly after he
gets bit there's no way of saying for
definite whether he's one of them or not
we also don't know how the virus passes
from the hybrids and whether that
increases the likelihood of their
victims becoming one either for the
purpose of the video though we will be
going through this like chung san is one
but yeah like i said we don't really
know they are a bit of a mystery and in
the season though we don't learn a lot
about them it does become clear that
they're basically super humans they
possess increased strength agility and
also heightened senses plus it seems
like they may even be able to heal over
time as guinam's eye gets less and less
bloody the more time that we spend with
him namrat is also extremely messed up
come episode 12 but after the 4 month
time jump we do see that she looks
healed and way less damaged than she was
this may be due to her consuming food or
perhaps repairing over time but it does
also appear that the variant zombies
heal as time goes on therefore it could
be possible that chiang sang will heal
too and potentially even resurrect at
some point another interesting thing
comes when the group revisit the
construction site to survey the damage
there anjo calls out to chung sang and
almost refuses to leave the scene now
it's only upon namra saying that she
doesn't smell anything that the pair
eventually decide to leave
let's go
i don't smell anything there's no one
here
yes i watch it with dubs not subs yeah
i'm trying to write a script here at the
same time you punk just just leave me
alone now this potentially means that
he's left however there is also the
possibility that the man got cooked so
bad he can't even smell him anymore
beyond that though the show does tease
his death quite a lot and there are even
points where they make it look like he's
been killed throughout the season i
genuinely thought that he died several
times and it was only upon the next
episode that it was revealed he was
still alive now there is a possibility
that they did his death and then the
reveal of it in episode 12 to show us
this time that it was over which would
fit in with the style of the season
however it could have been put in place
to make us think that he's been shown to
be dead before and then he always comes
back it's definitely an interesting
narrative device and should they want to
resurrect the character there are ways
that they could do it now the season
ends by teasing that there are more
people out there like namra living
amongst the abandoned zones we may end
up seeing chung-san again but personally
going off everything there is i do think
that he's gone for good never say never
though and obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on schroedinger's
chung-san is he alive is he dead let me
know in the comments below and if you
caught any other evidence he's still
live and kicking then i'd love to hear
it we are in competition right now and
giving away three copies of the june box
set on the 28th of feb and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the theories
if you pick the comments at random at
the end of the month and the winners of
the last one on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
the breakdown of the ending of all of us
are dead which will be linked on screen
right now we go over the full story and
also talk about what the ending could
mean for season two hopefully i see you
over there and with that out of the way
thanks for sitting through the video
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time take care peace